enterrement ouais enterrement dernière
sortie en boîte
gynécologue c'est quoi gynécologue c'est
docteur qui sait lire sur les lèvres
Jean petit con qui met les pieds sous la
table et les doigts dans la fille
confessionnal cabane de pêcheur oh
c'est joli vétérinaire gros bislam elle
est là gros Michelin qui pratique le
fils fucking sur les vaches sans être
inquiété par la justice c'est vrai qu'il
met le bras on le dit pas un mot
ils prennent 2 ans école sorte de
cassoulet on met les feuilles au devant
et les grandes saucisses derrière
bisexualité optimisation des orifices ça
va donc seul prison au monde où les
détenus se masturbent devant les enfants
à une gentille alors une propre je crois
que j'en ai pas